[Music]
today we are unboxing the brand new
playstation 5. i'm so excited to check
this out it's console season tech season
it is all of the things right now
let's stop talking and let's just open
this thing up
power cable
are you ready are you ready are you
ready are we all ready i'm ready i'm
ready oh my gosh everyone's ready
i don't know if i am ready okay
oh
[Music]
when they first revealed this i know
people have their opinions
but mine was that it looked pretty
awesome it's like a spaceship
oh dude wow wow it just looks cool
like this is cool this is big
whoa look at this
oh my gosh the inside of here it has
tiny
little playstation buttons on it so it
has like the square
the triangle the circle but very very
very
very small we're gonna need to get a
macro in this to even get the shot
so here it is the playstation 5. this is
just an unboxing so
not only are we going to unbox the
console but i do have some accessories
as well i think this looks cool
it's not a typical look for a console
it's it's futuristic it's fun
if you don't like it that's not my
problem i like it let's see what else we
have
we have the hd camera we've got the new
dual sense wireless controller which
this also came with once this is
exciting that we have
two and we have a dual sense charging
station
and we've got the new pulse 3d wireless
headset this actually
is a really cool headset look i wonder
if i can use these
for other things
instructions paper whoa here they are
these look so cool here's the headphones
do i look cool you have the right on the
right
i don't know yeah
hd camera personalize your gameplay
sharing
1080p capture background removal tool if
i ever caught myself make sure you
switch to 120 so you can
get the shot look at you
aren't you cute
here we go now we're opening up the dual
charger
this is great because this will free up
a usb slot for you
charger charger
charger charger for your charger this
feels
that's a nice weight oh my gosh
these buttons feel really nice that's
all
the triggers are so smooth wow
now we need another controller so it can
join its friend
that same pattern that is on the inside
of the ps5 with like the little
controller buttons are also on here but
it's so
so small like it's very hard to see oh
wow
yeah so cool
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's interesting because there's
really not much adjustment that you have
to do to this to fit your head so you
can see this little headband part this
just
automatically kind of slides up and down
there's like these little clips right
there
that'll allow it to slide so depending
upon i guess the size of your head this
just will automatically
just fit like magic these are pretty
comfortable but they do feel a little
bit heavier than i thought that they
were gonna feel
i just i love the look of this like it
just looks so futuristic
i'm looking at myself in the second
monitor because i'm so hyped about him
look at this i look like i'm about ready
to
command a spaceship maybe not but
just let me dream so all of the controls
are on the left side you have your game
and your chat so you can decide
what you want to hear more of there's
the off and the monitor button which
this will allow you to switch on or off
if you want to hear your voice there's a
volume button a microphone mute
usbc 3.5 millimeter headphone jack
and the on and off button so on the
front of the console we have two usb
slots there's a usb a usbc we have an
eject button and the power button and
this is
for the disc drive and then on the back
we have two more usb ports
ethernet hdmi and this is where
the power goes i like the cutout logo
this looks awesome
it's minimal but it's also not
minimal it's like somebody walking in
and like
whisper yelling hey
look at me so i'm sure some of you guys
have seen the tear downs of
both the xbox and the playstation
console but you guys can see that this
has the
cooling vents all around the side you
can see it goes all the way around the
top and then also
all around down the side i can't wait to
plug this in and actually try it out but
not
yet so here's the new controller so
excited to test this out i love
these buttons it just looks really sleek
it actually feels really good and the
buttons feel very very smooth
i'm excited to try out the haptic
feedback and the new adaptive triggers
it also has a built-in microphone and it
feels
feels nice i like the little kind of
slight grippiness that they have
added here do you want to touch it yeah
just put the
put your paw on that feel how smooth
these triggers are like
so so these adaptive triggers like it's
really cool because they in one of the
demos that they were showing
when you're like pulling a bow back
you'll actually feel the tension
and so like if you have a sword or
something you'll be able to sort of feel
what that feels like there's entire
departments that have been dedicated to
just programming
these triggers to give you that feedback
so here's the little stand that you can
put the playstation on
this is a very tall console so i think a
lot of people are probably going to want
to lay it down
go just like that
so that's all i have for today i will be
doing a follow-up video so if there's
anything else that you guys would like
me to test out
or any games that you'd like to see me
play leave those in the comments below i
will also be streaming on twitch i've
been streaming there a little bit since
the whole pandemic started so you can
check that out at twitch.tv
ijustine and be sure to subscribe to my
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
notified when i post new videos we cover
a lot of tech stuff here
not just specific to gaming but phones
and drones and everything in between
so i will see you guys in your
subscription box if it
is working okay let's go turn this on
i'm done i'm done i don't wanna talk
anymore i don't wanna talk i just wanna
play
games all day
you